foreign
[Music]
news you need to know today's show is
brought to you by Pluto TV which offers
hundreds of free live channels and 1 000
and thousands of free on-demand movies
yeah once you hit one thousand one
thousand one I'm sorry you're out one
thousand and one Dalmatians coming up
secret post credit scenes I wonder what
it's for and also clio's return oh yeah
who's that
and is that mephisto's music we're
here's music I guess so all right
Mephisto too sexy we have we have koi
genre oh we got Jessica who cares we got
Tommy Bechtel yes you know what I am
wearing a hat that is made for heads
that are too big and I believe the
company is called lamud that makes them
and I will tag them and then I want to
thank them for sending me a hat and if
you haven't liked And subscribe yet to
this video you're dead to me you're dead
to me trash bags if you want a Halloween
miracle and me to you know be nice to
you for a day you'd better smash that
like button right now wow okay okay okay
okay geez Louise the last but not least
there's no personal blogs
I apologize what's up roomies what's up
Breakers hey we'll see girl fast
Jessica's about to tell you about
today's Redemption do not no no okay let
me finish it let me finish it
you guys fall is here and Halloween is
just around the corner so we decided for
every 100 in super chats we're going to
pumpkin spice supplies something please
don't should never have been pumpkin
spice I'm talking hot dogs shrimp
cocktails no you name it and you get to
vote on what we try
not so fun this is not official pumpkin
spice that was made by professors
producer John bought some spices there's
no shrimp he wants us to specify no
personal plugs no shrimp because that
reminds me if you want the best shrimp
dinner in town go to Handy Jack's shrimp
Buffet uh listen I've got a tender tummy
today and I got a butt model tonight
okay so do not and I repeat do not Super
Chat because otherwise I'm gonna Super
Chat and lose my modeling well we
already got a super chat from Christian
unpronounceable said pumpkin sucking
lips those are back
four days left to PSL season I went I
went to Handy Jacks once to get uh like
a shrimp scampi and I didn't get that
but what I did get a handy Jax was a
handy Jack yes he's there the logo is
just a hand that goes like this
it's time for headlines why
first the handy Jack says
during the graphics not during the
graphics flip it out oh
Devin King save your money John just
plainly sadly played them
I just picture him back there going like
this just disappointed deadline
deadline is doubling down on its
reporting that Sasha Baron Cohen will be
in Iron Heart they're reporting he's
been scanned for CGI though it's not
clear if he will be completely CGI or
undergo a transformation oh so like he
would maybe be Sasha Baron Cohen as like
Randy the guy who owns the electronic
store and then he's like you know what
perhaps we could make a deal
outside of the shop tomorrow
how you doing Joe Mephisto I mean
possibly I mean I'm like I mean I think
when you have a meeting at Marvel which
is like like sit in this chair real fast
you're like okay what just happened or
like oh we scanned you my first thought
is like you sign on for one movie to be
in it and then 10 movies that your image
is in I think that Mephisto is just oh
they just owned him now I bet it's
definitely that for certain roles and
Mephisto is one of those roles like just
in case also Sasha Banks kind of the
craziest things and it's like we're
gonna hold on to your likeness real
quick before you do another movie that's
dangerous they should have a journey
Knoxville at this point yeah there's
certain people they should protect them
Ross marquad on on the payroll you guys
like everyone's voice yeah he was the
new Red Skull right most people didn't
realize that he was playing right
explain please Ross marquette's an actor
who's in like The Walking Dead
videos of him online uh him and Tom
Hiddleston are so good at doing people's
voices but Ross Marquardt is like
incredible at it but he played Red Skull
in Infinity war and end game I wore a
mirror
I actually have Ross call my mom
sometimes that's a great impression and
I think they just get along good
just call your mom you actually call
your mom and Tom he's like
that guy I love you I know when it's
that guy impersonating you man quite
frankly he's nicer Bucky Barnes ATL my
hair does smell like pumpkin spice oh
God people please I I know that we we
encourage zero chat but do not send in
super chess today I'm begging my beard
smells like the blood of the innocent
no the article report
that Chris Summers has also joined the
cast of ironheart she's primarily a
voice actress we all know Chris Thomas I
think she's like she's like number five
she's uh uh fans of a different world
but like it could look like a moment in
the conversation
okay
new rock stars you can prevent me from
personal plugs speaking of which
Johnny's plugs and things is the
greatest place for adapters and adapted
units you cannot provoke the chat into
donating there is no middle ground
either I promote like hell or you stop
getting them to give money and if any of
you idiots give money to the super chats
today I'm finding you because I got all
your addresses up here I got an implant
in my head that gives me all your home
addresses I'm gonna come knock on your
door and I'm gonna pants your dad
make it my pants his tuxedo off his
Goose they're gonna make us
inspires hot dog either way either way
you guys Cree Summer says also joined
the cast of Iron Heart we know that
she's primarily a voice actress maybe
she'll play riri's AI because we have in
wakanda forever we have uh what's his
name doing the voice oh uh Trevor Noah
Trevor Noah doing the voice so maybe we
have Chris Summers doing it for her that
would be kind of sick um and one comic
run Riri develops an AI based on her
deceased best friend Natalie Washington
it's naturally an at-a-l-i it's like how
Kevin is
that's a sweet tribute that's a little
creepy what about Natalie how's
Natalie's family feel about that well
it's her best friend it's a trivial it's
a robot voice
thank you
would hate that I don't need anything
except your voice
it's more chaotic than it was so chaotic
and I'm so nervous about eating this
pumpkin spice hot dogs
it's making it's Brandon's gonna have a
heart the faster we get through this
show the faster this Show's gonna wrap
up we can beat it before they get there
called it a pumpkin Glizzy oh no oh it
looks offensive oh God you guys during
an appearance on Jimmy Kimmel Live
Charlize Theron was tight-lipped about
her future in the MCU her exchanger Kim
will one like this you play Kimmel I'll
play Kimmel I'm going to do camels
do you know yeah maybe you don't know
this yeah do you know if it is uh if we
can see clear again I think I know I
mean unless I'm sure they can change
their mind depending on what I say on
this show
whoa
I'm not saying anything yeah yeah I love
I also love that now they're getting
more which I I don't mind getting more
aggressive about like you guys know I
can't talk about it all right so I love
when people are just straight up like
why are you even asking me I don't
understand why people waste like even I
mean Kendall's part of this any company
like I don't know maybe it's part of
like reminding people but also that's
what I think
that it's like just like oh just keep it
in people's minds but on a red carpet
when someone asks them like what do you
do you're wasting the 30 seconds uh is
Kim only is Kim on the MCU have they
ever played like uh
it pops up that's what I was gonna say I
was wondering if like if they've done a
clip of one of the they did Jaylen I
thought too well they have like didn't
one of the TV shows recently show like
the night like Talking Heads at night
talking about I'm literally trying to
think about you right wasn't he in like
Iron Man 2 or something like that yeah I
forget uh if you know in the if you're
watching I mean Francisco you sick sick
person uh you guys will start a poll on
what we're gonna be eating if we pass
100 I don't know I don't know I don't
know already uh I just know and she
hoped they did use a lot of the action
totaled up I can do the math way over
100
is filling up sorry no you're good I was
just saying She-Hulk I know that they
used a lot of actual La uh news anchors
oh yeah so like all of LA's like
actual real and actually candid and you
know
they shouldn't have got us in there I'm
holding out for Abbott Elementary one
day why why are you putting all the bad
ones out there they're all bad ones
pumpkin spice pineapple is probably
amazing oh he didn't put the pineapple
which is Peppers
it looks bad it looks bad I'm not eating
it I'm sorry I'm not eating the clock
every man is to have a code I'm not even
the pumpkin Square squawk I've done so
much for you people the doctor said my
intestines are Dr nasty is running out
of animals yeah he can't put any more
throats in me I've had enough throws
I've already got 15 throats in me can we
cut can we clip that out yeah why is
that gross um
goats got a lot of throats inside him
okay I'll just I worry about all of this
way it looks like we're grabbing the
pumpkin spice hot dogs
well John's more than happy to think I
mean he's just he's just kidding so John
said he just came in for the show I
don't get any enjoyment out of this and
that is look at his face look at his
face
they look like Cincinnati chili dogs
why is there mustard on it you guys need
to know what this smells like you put
this smells like this is straight
powdered cinnamon he also like
microwaved these hot dogs with the Buns
on with the Buns on
Shake It Off look at how much is still
on there baby okay it smells like it we
all have to take a bite together as a
unit if a sparkle pony at Burning Man
opened her own pumpkin spice store that
was a Yankee Candle in Salem
Massachusetts I'm gonna dip it in the
water maybe it'll change it no then you
can't you won't have water in your
dreams
really quick oh god
um
cheers
tips
[Laughter]
oh no
no
no
that's so gross yeah I can't feel it
you Tommy's mic you might be
what oh the mustard kind of helps I
think no
no he didn't warm this up at all he took
this straight out of the bag this might
be the words like the worst part the
worst part is it's like an Oscar Meyer I
can say sweet this is just a normal
baloney hot dog I was sweet eating so
much yeah I need kosher I'll be fine
this is way worse than anything if I
feel 15 pounds lighter oh God if I ate
one of those hot dogs every day I'd be
down to 185 in no time I felt like I was
doing the cinnamon challenge on a slab
of meat oh it's just sweet it's just
affecting me at like a molecular level
oh it's so bad well that's a pumpkin
suck not a pumpkin spice yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and declare people in the chat
wanted me to eat yeah
oh
wow
so we get each other we both have
throats that have been through a lot of
damage you guys if John did this on an
only fans would you subscribe uh Black
Panther wakanda foreign
I can't even look at it freaking puke
it's not even 3 30 we can't even say F's
and so much effed up stuff has already
happened
okay so much
black panther what kind of if you guys
donate anymore I will jump through this
screen if one more dime is donated I'm
tearing my microphone off and I'm not
gonna be on the background I'm gonna
shove this hot dog down to your guys
actually that's instead of these trash
bags will try and get me out if you guys
donate three thousand dollars I'll leave
the show forever
yeah we're buying out Tommy's cotton buy
them out throw up bro listen I gotta I
got a meeting with top brass after this
this could be my last show anyway so
let's get to mandatory fun one
black panther wakanda forever premiered
last night you guys and we have some
light spoilers but not actually when I
deliver We're Not Gonna Give You license
it's just one little one one little it's
not even a spoiler it only included one
mid-credit scene yes it only included
one I'm sorry I just got a little taste
of like you know there's a little hot
dog left in your mouth
everybody's had like a wiener soaking in
your mouth for a bit I'm not going to
get into the content of that scene
but there's been some speculation online
you guys speculation that
um Marvel was possibly emitted a second
post-credits scene to avoid spoilers
recently in Age of Ultron Spider-Man's
post credit scene was not shown to
pre-release audiences nor was the Howard
the Duck scene from the Guardians of
Galaxy vol 1 which genuinely honestly I
hate to be that person do that yeah do
that I'm so tired of variety
I deleted all my social media yeah
because of variety and the thing is like
okay you guys they don't get in trouble
exactly and yeah nothing happens nothing
happens they're not graceful about it
they don't go out camping about it
certain other pundits about it it's very
frustrating I know can we go back to
something
yes honey there's still so much food I
don't want in my mouth no Age of Ultron
there's a Spider-Man post-credit scene
Civil War okay
I I thought it was so early I was like
yeah
what is this oh yeah
you're sick you're sick Mark Barnhart
free girl you're on our side Nina
Tina
my boo thing
you gave it down
also worth noting nearly all MCU movies
have included a post-credits scene and
if there aren't two the mid credit scene
is the one that gets cut yeah uh the
exception here is the Age of Ultron that
had only a mid-credit scene a mid-credit
teams of Thanos and end game of course
had no post-credit scenes shout out to
the MCU Wiki from the fandom for helping
us with that research over there Junior
Wiki save my buns on Rogue Theory as
well yeah thank you thank you Wiki
yeah it's great to check things like
that but yeah because we all know at
least from the very first one from Iron
Man there's something at the very very
end yeah they like really set the tone
for that yeah
it's a screening for them to only show a
mid-credit one means like there's
probably there's probably a thing and
I'm glad they held it
girl doesn't need to smell this thing
that's fair only beards uh the cinnamon
Kings
I saw the cinnamon Kings play at the
Indiana State Fair they're still great
they're still great yeah it sucks that
their drummer was racist
I was like Brandon what are you talking
about them of the races
uh uh so as we get closer to the release
of black panther there's always going to
be more and more of these kind of clips
and like little featurettes that come
out uh some of the castes we were saying
they were on Jimmy Kimmel Live last
night uh because they had the premiere
right there right next door at the El
Capitan uh they put out some more Clips
I think we have uh some of these clips
let's go ahead and roll that first one
Johnny you left without saying it would
it had
how you regret not being there with all
of you
it was not easy
he was
King and black panther to everyone
at who me
he was everything
Brandon I know very much
don't die because I'll be upset I'm
doing my best
so I just had to eat a pumpkin spice hot
dog so clock sticking now they really
want us to do this pickle neck 28 years
off our lives from that
um so this is interesting right like
probably early in in the film they don't
appear to be in like funeral attire or
life celebration time whatever that
ceremony is going to be with the
all-white so maybe this is before that
maybe this is after that but pretty
early on uh we still have no idea what
happened to the child I don't want to
know until the movie comes out but this
was interesting because we do know from
the film description right some of it
takes place like a year after he's been
dead for like a year yeah like well
that's right yeah she said that like
shuri's still not dealing with it well a
year after so I don't know if this
movie's gonna have a time Jump maybe we
see the effects right after Charles
passing and then jump ahead a year that
or is this do we know if this might be
like an anniversary
yeah maybe they're doing it on the first
anniversary of his death we also don't
know what uh you know ceremonies and
traditions exist in wakanda right so
what are I mean like what an incredible
uh task to thread the needle they've had
to do for previews of this movie of like
real life absolute horrible situation
happens and this young way too young
person passes away who's the star of
this film so they have to put out Clips
like this that are addressing the
character that are so not normally
Marvel yeah moods and attitudes and it's
like that's a a compelling clip for a
Marvel movie is amazing and it kind of
makes me go like when people are
critical of Marvel movies being like oh
they're not real movies they're just
action sequences with little things
mixed in I'm like come on those are two
incredible actors having an emotional
Moment Like give Marvel a little more
credit yeah I think the maturation of
the Marvel universe is really important
to look at and I thought it would come
through like Deadpool and Dick jokes but
I I do like that we're addressing things
and getting like this whole phase has
been about death and mourning and in its
own way and Trauma and therapy and I
think it's really smart of them to
address things in the marketing
beforehand for those people but also for
this movie that I have not seen to deal
with the ramifications of real life
there's also so many different people
that love like Black Panther and it a
lot of people that stand for like I feel
like my mom is one of those people that
I was like yeah I love black panthers or
like background on all her phone
everything but she didn't really know
that much about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but she was like this is
something that I want them to address
and she needs to know that they're
addressing it before she even goes and
sees it how pumped was your mom for your
interview with Eli Roth today sorry she
uh she texted me and she said I'm so
proud of you you did really good we are
all so proud of you is that archived can
we yeah it's on Instagram on the new
Rockstar's Instagram Jessica is like
legitimately a huge I genuinely am yeah
you're back to a childhood so this was
like very awesome it was I I was like
baby Jessica's so happy I made my senior
project in high school was on him so
that's incredible what a moment
I'm so sorry I know that we've been
changing and going all over the place
today we've gotten like four comment
chats that are like can we please see
the back of Brandon's jacket it's really
nice he has a really good everyone's
been complimenting the h m black boy
[Music]
one thing I will say about that clip
though it does kind of show I have my
grand theory that it's gonna be the side
characters that create the chaos in this
that maybe well that may be Nakia and a
koye are like not on the same page and
there's Strife like I think it's the war
that might be coming between the
wakandans and the talcons might be
caused not by Namor and or shuri queen
raimonda but by a tumor or by Anika or
by Side characters making her move and
then their leaders feel like I have to
stick with my people something I'm
really excited about now that we've seen
a little bit more and again a dodging as
much as I can is that it looks to me
like what we expect from the the floor
flow of the movie is going to be
different like I don't think what we've
seen in the trailers isn't it anyway
like they were very like edit edit and I
think we're gonna watch the movie be
like that goes there and it's going to
be not the way we expect which I really
want them to do more of I I hate when
Marvel Age of Ultron is actually the
worst one for me where I felt like I'd
seen all the videos and I was just
putting scenes together in the middle
and I was like okay I've seen this movie
yeah oh I want nothing I'm that person
that genuinely I'm like I watch this all
in the movie and I'm still gonna watch a
movie again
if I wasn't in this job if I was like an
accountant I'd watch the first trailer I
would find out when it's released and do
nothing else what you mentioned it how
they kind of stay away from the third
act they don't always like to show third
act stuff in their trailers you know
like shangshi kind of had a little we
saw a little bit of the battle and every
time they showed a little bit more a new
piece was added too yeah like digitally
which was always funny uh we do have one
more clip from their appearance on Jimmy
Kimmel this one is kind of interesting
to note for some reason let's take a
look at that of my dorm get out hey I'm
warning you do not take another step
toward me see how they teach the
children to treat their guests
oh
despair in here
I like it
oh my God that was too much sorry sorry
for 11 days I should have ran away this
is the dorm room uh for Riri Williams as
John was quick to put out this is the
nicest dorm room I've ever seen him my
my dorm room
yeah yeah yeah yeah like a cot with no
mattress y'all weren't going to MIT MIT
has I went to the RIT Central New York
this is we think this is Boston right
like if they're at MIT should be she's
got this but I've never seen anything I
know is she a Kennedy maybe maybe uh my
dorm room was where they used to do the
psychological studies that have since
been outlawed uh and every night we'd
fall asleep in the mornings we'd wake up
with messages carved into our skin by
the ghost left behind him I experiment
patience but that's a nice storm were
they nice at least like uh they were
mostly call your mom back yeah you're a
side sleeper and I like that oh one of
them was yes cool actually so yeah very
nice looking dorm room oh boy John's
coming over because because I think you
Maniacs decided to keep setting in super
chats I mean I will say thank you for
your super chats uh I don't Jameel said
in a Super Chat saying I think you look
nice sending love to all of you from an
ex-trent New Jersey resident for 18
years these are pickles and I gotta say
that Top Dog not sitting very well
these are pickles I'm taking the one
that's not done on both sides
she did that on purpose
this one looks like it has a little more
sugar which you get ready Tommy
immediately ate it is I'm a little
afraid of a sugar pickle
whatever this powder is just my tongue
first I hate it
oh that's nasty do it it's okay the
aftertaste is just pickle and I love
that
no it's not yeah
the sugar came back but then you get
that cinnamon on the end and that nutmeg
oh God Honestly though we have to rate
it hot dog was not as bad yeah I already
eat the hot chocolate again actually no
I was gonna say the other way no I like
the pickle more than that Pickle's nasty
I'm almost 40.
actually I will say no thank you to
Justin Gillespie for sending in a very
generous Super Chat this is me J right
me wanted pumpkin spice pepperoni pizza
absolutely not uh GSU Eagle you want
those pumpkin pumpkin spice pickles
while we ate them uh thank you Mark
Barnhart Alex H Devin King Nina you why
are you thanking them I don't know I
don't deserve our thanks I'm just trying
to keep talking to the the vomit
Building inside of my esophagus doesn't
come flying out uh the NBA folks the
National Basketball Association they
also released a kind of song let's talk
about some of the scores from last year
I have no idea over the Lakers LeBron
not getting it done they're owing four
folks what what sport don't you want the
nutmeg is like really I don't know I
watch horses
it sticks it's like the acidity of the
nutmeg that makes like a heavy base it
won't swallow down I don't like hockey
that's white people [ __ ] okay okay
let's uh offend the three hockey fans we
have in the world
in the Seattle I like to see oh the
Kraken
so yeah the NBA they put out like a a
kind of small featurette trailer last
night that had a couple of new things in
it I think we have a clip from that damn
all my life
[Music]
running all my life
foreign
they came from the water
they had superhuman Strife he's coming
for the surface world
that can't be good
[Music]
slice
now is our time to strike
told them
their best participated eight minute
clip hey so The Simpsons name LeBron
James for that okay you have him buying
a pickleball leagues and now this okay
when is the when is The Nightmare gonna
end you know LeBron's asking for a
franchise in Las Vegas but I don't think
Adam Silver is going to give it to him
the ownership of the NBA historically is
a blend unlike other sports
traditionally owned by older white men
the NBA has Venture capitalists young
Tech Bros and people of color it's a
more diverse ownership group but I don't
think they're gonna let a player step
right off the court into the GM spot
into the ownership I think you've killed
the show Thomas it looks like we've got
zero concurrent we faded to Black we
were black
um so some things I would like to talk
about and this uh featurette that maybe
one of you watched uh we have that kind
of giant whale cresting out of the water
yes which we saw you've seen in a
trailer that you've watched I've seen a
whale
and this was start kind of coming out of
the water this seems to be their form of
transportation I don't know we saw so
much from writing it like yeah but this
leads me to this kind of again you saw
this in a trailer you saw and we saw it
again here this giant metal structure
that they're repelling down and in this
channel we saw this very incredible like
fight choreography of uh who I assume
was sure he is black panther kind of
going along it again we were kind of
comparing this to you know some of the
criticisms of the first black panther
film The like Panther on Panther fight
in darkness it was dark suits and it was
hard this look great right awesome my
thing is like what is this giant
structure okay if if intello can like
their technology is more uh for lack of
a better world like primitive or natural
or organic I don't know are they
building giant superstructures a giant
ship like that's what I don't know who
owns this giant pig that they're jumping
out off on is it like are they pulling a
wakanda where we meet them and we think
it's like oh they're not very Advanced
and then it turns out oh we're hypers
like the meteor thing adding them as
well I imagine they're pretty far you
know ahead of us maybe they're not as
far as wakanda but we yeah I could see
them having underwater Tech that would
reveal itself because they had these
face things right and I I don't assume
that so that the telekins can like
breathe above Air Above there they can
have this Advanced I don't know how
they're handling the pressure issue but
maybe they're not gaming they're very
strong I don't know how benthic they are
huh science teacher I remembered that
word thick benthic I heard thick all
right
I know a guy named all right okay okay
my mistake I don't think I'm gonna be
ass modeling tonight guys I'm gonna be
honest that last pumpkin spice pickle
man we're only like 70 away from another
guys Tommy's ass is on a bail right now
okay so I didn't mind the pickle as much
of that hot dog hot dog
hot dog over there it's like it's like
there's a dead body decomposing next to
items it winked I don't know they'll
never pay enough money for it please I'm
begging you um
I'm begging them these people have
nothing going for them they showed you
their money figures what's left over
goes to the spice
I need a pumpkin spice bowling at this
point
so yeah they have this breathing
apparatus right which I don't think is
like a jellyfish they grab and stick on
their face yeah John John caught that
joke like a full light bulb later yeah
uh I don't think it's like something
they're just finding and singing on
their face they've obviously built it so
I they might have like a surprise tent
that comes out uh we'll have to see uh I
love like the kind of anime looks to
these fights where you have uh you know
you have Neymar kind of like skidding in
midair doing a little slide with his
little wingy feet you have this kind of
sideways fight on this giant metal
structure just just very cool a very
cool stuff indeed but also so you know
we know Riri Williams has done this
obviously they're like yeah is she gonna
fight underwater Yeah
Boy Diana
give me my mic real quick
maybe it's not my fault in what Universe
what happened yesterday is not your
fault oh I it my hands were are big and
they sometimes hit things by accident
um flying a microphone around like a
like a like a parade
I will litigate this what I'm Who the
game is right now this is my last
question for you guys do you think is
going to be able to go underwater or
would she be above 100 I mean it would
not make sense for her to be in a movie
with the potentially villainous
aqua-based folks right and then the suit
can go into space or Iron Man's mock two
and on right so I imagine it looks like
her propulsion system is not the
repulsory tech it looks like Firebase
is that going to work underwater do we
think
and then also if this is the best way
that the total kids could win any fight
is like go super deep that's it lower
the more pressure just let them go yeah
but then just push water out push water
up there's eventually they'll have to
come to the surface and that's where me
and Riri will be waiting with our
Firepower I'm so afraid of this
come over here well Tommy a while while
John prepares our our utter demise why
don't you tell them about some good
things I think yeah we want to thank
butcherbox for sponsoring the break room
today and at the risk of sounding a bit
choogy Supermarket protein is made y'all
No Cap no cab okay Boomers the selection
is very confusing and what I do buy is
not super transparent about what's in it
when it comes to Quality luckily butcher
box has been coming through in the
clutch I will say this Tommy I agree
with you because like I try and buy the
right things at the supermarket but
they're very tricky with their wording
sometimes yeah in caves free but had
hormones I don't know what is this Farm
what is your foot is open what does
farm-raised even mean what does it mean
I was raised on a farm I wouldn't eat me
I would what's the tilapia if there's a
plane that crashes on an island and I
have I'm stuck with you first what if I
cover myself on pumpkin spice then I'm
gonna absolutely oh God hey yo we're
doing it sorry sorry butcher box I get
peace of mind when it comes to buying
meat but your box takes the guesswork
out of finding High Quality Meats and
Seafood you could trust 100 grass-fed
beef free-range organic chickens pork
raised crate free crate-free lifestyle
forever and wild caught Seafood always
you mainly raised you guys with no
antibiotics or added hormones get just
what you want delivered straight to your
doorstep free shipping for the
continental U.S and no surprise Feast
you're gonna surprise fee that's some
other company it ain't butcher box I
guarantee it tears from a variety of box
plan options from curated to customize
and change your plan whenever you want
are you a grizzly bear that just wants a
big box of salmon guess what they'll do
it for you are you a tiny little otter
that just wants sardines I don't think
they have that okay am I never any quest
to eat better and save money butcher box
is my new teammate and like Dawson Knox
it's running a beautiful post fade
actually that would be a flag route
opposed to the inside to train a
beautiful post straight towards the goal
post four six bills wins Sunday Night
Football for opening on NBC there may I
only get six for Touchdown then you kick
an extra point and run a two-point
conversion from the two yard line the
main course for Thanksgiving dinner
could sometimes be a main source of
stress not anymore my friends butcherbox
is offering our listeners free turkey
sign up today at butcherbox.com break
room and use code break room to get one
10 to 14 pound turkey free in your first
box that's butcherbox.com break room use
the code break room to give us a little
bit of uh of Good Good Karma with the
with the butcher box people and save
yourself and get that nice turkey claim
that deal now turkey we also want to
thank Pluto TV for sponsoring the break
room all week and our house at the
dragon finale breakdown Pluto tv offers
hundreds of free live channels and
thousands of free on-demand movies three
two one it's time for mandatory fun
I'm not having fun I like that quick
countdown I am tasting nothing but my
stomach is so much mandatory our
stomach's feel Grosso play the graphic
the most hit it again
back in the control room he's gonna
bring some sick food
no wait why does the chicken flavor it
looks like baby doo doo I didn't want to
buy a whole bunch of chips
oh we can't cut because John's out here
get it off the tablet
all right oh there's a hard piece of
cinnamon right here I don't like the
John's such a demon he stirred that I
know you take the first bite Tommy you
get your butt over I'm not I can't I'm
sorry I don't I don't want Tommy to bark
I will actually puke I cannot I'm sorry
I love you guys
are the worst I'm so much more afraid
but it's in everything in this there's
no good part
scared
okay ready
it's so gross
give me a joke oh my God it's so sweet
this is the worst episode of this show
we've ever done
oh my God it's so gross it's so sweet
why is it so sweet oh my God so stupid
we thought this would be a good idea it
was a horrible idea who thought it was a
good idea
okay
no I've been eating this girl well
that's supposed to be some pumpkin spice
things that didn't look and taste awful
get that off the table then we can
continue with the show
they're out of voted for pineapple why
won't you vote for pineapples when your
entire fan base is mentally ill they're
not gonna vote for the good thing okay
oh they don't even know a pineapple
slide those are rich man's fruits thank
you Diana Santos thank you Z is me oh
that looks like straight up splattered
[ __ ] okay thank you to me that is awful
you're all bad people I will not touch
it mandatory fun look I don't even know
if I want to do this segment for you
guys because it's something you like and
I don't want to give you anything to
reward yourself
you donate One More Dollar I swear to
God I'm taking the camera away and each
for every dollar that comes in I turn
one camera off when all four are gone
there's no more break room ever uh and
guess what
thank you they did a pull and do we need
to punish Tommy if he doesn't
participate and they said yes 83. that's
fine punish me what's what's what could
be a worse punishment than baby [ __ ] on
a Dorito thank you Francisco
filipando
I literally ate a Pocky one chip for
your people I ate a one chip no one else
did besides Zach and he's not here so
I'm off the hook for that the one chip
is My Punishment like lingering um
what's this mandatory mandatory fun
let's let's cleanse the palette guys
let's cleanse that listen oh the
Guardians of the Galaxy Christmas uh
holiday special is a Christmas theme uh
but hopefully other holidays will be
included as well as it is called the
holiday special uh we actually broke in
last night to Kevin feige's office so I
can stole some of the music uh that's
gonna be in the special and it's pretty
crazy how some of the songs came out uh
so koi actually I had a song I wanted
you to sing okay this is to the tune of
the 12 Days of Christmas okay so I was
hoping you'd go first and sing that for
us this is long that was only after what
we just did oh I I didn't know that I
know there's a mandatory complaints
the number one complainer it's mandatory
fun yeah that's right
on the first day of their special the
Guardians gave to me Groot as a
full-grown Tree on the second day of
their special the Guardians gave to me
to Peter's grieving and a Groot as a
full-grown Tree on the third day of
their special the Guardians gave to me
three rocket smoking two Peter's
grieving and a Groot as a full-grown
Tree on the fourth day of their special
the Guardians gave to me four ghosts of
Yonder three rocket smoking two Peter's
grieving and a Groot as a full grocery
on the fifth day of their special the
Guardians gave to me five post credit
scenes four ghosts of yondu 3 rocket
smoking two Peter's grieving Anna Groot
as a full-grown Tree on the sixth damn
they're special the Guardians gave to me
I cut it in half six nebula scowling
five post credit scene four ghosts of
yondu 3 rocket smoking two Peter's
grieving at a Groot as a full-grown tree
that was beautiful yes beautiful
wonderful now that's what you and I are
gonna duet this one I think this one's
cool it's called Uh uh well it's uh it's
a it's a pretty famous tune I think
they're doing a cover are you sure I
know it ah
I don't wanna rock for Christmas
there is just one thing with these that
will make my heart so happy he can
Sprout his own nice wreaths there's just
one guy that I need he came from a
sapling seed make my wish take root all
I want for Christmas is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it looks like
[Applause]
okay this is Carol of the Guardians
hmm
barked from the Groot stuck in my boot
track seems to say do things by way
Christmas is here where I know where
what is this day Peter will not say
rough bark wolf howl Cosmo to ground
nebula is born with this old horde
mantis can feel quill needs to heal this
holiday is coming our way oh how he
grows brute makes the snow rocket will
groan his feelings don't quickly he
builds Tech that will kill fabulous
what the hell is this thing called
Christmas what the hell is this thing
called Christmas
beautiful you're wonderful beautiful uh
and then I found one song that's
actually a take on an old Elvis oh okay
I think it's something about Austin
Butler oh okay I'm so sad
[Music]
thinking about you
you're all red mixed with green since
your dad squashed you to
Smithereens the other versions of you
were acting really mean you're very into
doing all right all they do is cruise
and fight
but I'll have a blue blue holiday
special without you that's of course
Peter Quill singing oh oh that's very
modeling I like that very sad very sad
they don't all have to be happy
that was beautiful all the time you have
one more there's one more there's one
more we'll come to him this one was
called Peter's lament okay
I saw Peter kissing Gamora shoe
underneath the Ben and tar last night
it's a shoe she left behind and Peter's
lost his mind and now that gamora's gone
we'll let him keep this shoe to keep him
kind then I saw Peter stroking
Gamora shirt the one she you have to
never fit her right oh how funny it
would have been if rocket had only seen
Peter's stroking gamora's trash last
night
that's great guys that's all the time we
have for the brakes
we're not done yet we saw that's it I
think we're done that's great okay let's
say that's the time I think we're all
set uh MLS beats just said a very
generous Super Chat yeah I think we're
good though I don't think we need to get
together what's asking koi which I think
is funny where where do you rank what
kind of forever in your Facebook
breaking so I haven't seen it so it's in
phase four and I haven't seen it but I
assume that it's in Phase five all right
it's my number one Facebook why would
you put the same disgusting thing back
in I will not touch that all the movies
out in Phase five it's my favorite mac
and cheese I want to lose myself well
Franco did ask and we can all kind of
like speak to this what three things
does wakanda Forever need to have for
you to be satisfied with the film now I
will say these kind of things are
dangerous and I want everyone out there
to remember that as you spend years
gearing up as you spend years gearing up
for these movies
know you're here it's going to come out
and you're like oh we're going to get
this we're going to get that and by the
time you get there I'm a parent we've
all heard this like yeah you know going
into this movie being like there better
be storm there better be Doom uh and
there better be Magneto showing up is
it's never going to get you anywhere
because like the movie's about other
people right like all you're there for
is like that's fine you want to know my
three what are your three things oh okay
she'll be in it yeah
name one those three people coming yeah
you're great a good deal I'm gonna like
it uh I want Integrity
it needs to be yeah that hero got a long
time ago too high no no but I wanted
like the first movie is so important and
so profound in what it was able to do I
need that Integrity uh I need a a third
act action set piece that does more than
just like punching like I wanted to have
some weight uh and then three uh I want
to feel a sense of closure in losing
t'challa that doesn't feel like it it uh
kneecaps uh where the legacy of black
panther can go I feel that I feel that
those are my real answers
I hope the movie has full frontal from
whom Bullpen your pen iteration uh Sean
cheese
that's way worse than two parts
decapitations
heads on spikes uh and uh and a whale
being cut open from mouth to tail and
its guts pouring out all over the ocean
cause I'm bad Tommy now the cinnamon
made my brain go broken
I would like this episode broke all of
us I would like it definitely I'm yeah
it does kind of like make a definite
choice at the end the prep time takes
longer than the show's supposed to go we
don't have to eat it just as a heads up
don't get it too hot please I'll burn my
lips going to the gym after this
I ran this morning I'm gonna hurl my
guts out did you make me a Glizzy the
micro the mac and cheese in the
microwave as a punishment for 19
guacamole
oh oh no
what are you doing a little a little
theater of the
absurdy is again I'll help this is it
I'm leaving after the show let's
celebrate the outro
are you trying to move the camera I
don't know how to focus that bad boy
oh Jessica's touching the equipment this
is I went to school you did great you
did great Jessica's now the DP yeah we
have a new DP three two one
no Tommy Tommy Tommy oh Tommy's gonna
die cut Tom his way
cut his mic bro I'm so
he's just doing that to leave so he
doesn't have to eat the mac and cheese
oh no he doesn't want to eat the mac and
cheese
uh Coy here's the question for you uh we
got this super chat from uh Max Savage
yes Max Savage was asking if he thinks
if we think that gun and saffron will
push for Batgirl to get release now that
they're early they can legally they
cannot legally do it like the whole way
they made the tax thing yeah like so if
the if the film is destroyed and or
rendered and it will be released that is
how they get the money back for it and
then that can also people keep saying
like well why don't they just cancel
every movie somebody doesn't want that
only happens with Acquisitions it has to
be during emerging yeah like any company
if you acquire something you consider a
loss you can write it off so this is a
one-of-one scenario which unfortunately
means we don't get that movie that I
really wanted to see as well yeah but
there's also nothing and what's even
worse is I feel like gun and saffron are
gonna get asked that for the next 10
years right and there's nothing and I'm
sure when they met with zazlab that was
I'm sure they brought it up and then he
was like yeah there's nothing they can
do and I will say folks
uh I haven't seen it obviously it wasn't
finished very early reports were all
like it's not it's it's best it needed a
lot of work sure and then once it got
canceled it became this thing of like oh
it's perfect and put it out there what's
interesting I wanted to see it too it
had practical stuff but like maybe maybe
we don't know take another show about it
later yeah I was afraid the Snyder cup
was going to be is like it was this
thing people had idealized right and
then by the time it came they think it's
gonna fix everything but when I think
about I was impressed like I enjoyed the
Snyder cut but I did not expect to after
all the idealization even the dog
doesn't want to eat this one Jessica is
trying I got you I got it awful John so
avoid the Frozen Hearts because this
Frozen party can you point to which
parts are frozen I'll get down she'll
back inside
you don't like me on cameras John
oh sorry Dash I'll go back I'll go back
this is the fan can you show it can you
show it
I mean this is just a TV have you guys
ever had a child this is what you find
in the diaper right there why does
everything vaguely resemble poop today
John's just pooping and things and
trickiness you guys well we'll go out on
a bite of this hellish concoction but
before we do we want to remind you guys
that Pluto tv offers hundreds of free
live channels smells like cheese and
thousands of free movies on demand uh
you guys are crazy they have this
delicious cinnamon pineapple we could
have been eating dumping it all over the
floor Tommy Tommy stole a pumpkin spice
John took it off the thing it was
[ __ ] awesome that was great uh we
thank you guys for joining us today here
on the bread group uh we'll have a great
show here tomorrow the week's not over
yet baby
tomorrow on the edges because I like the
actual uh make sure you like And
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already uh John is this the Trader Joe's
squash join us here tomorrow guys on the
breaker from our variant break room here
at new Rockstar's headquarters never
again we hope you have a great rest of
your Thursday we'll see you here
tomorrow real bad keep it scary all
weekend keep it Gucci to moochie we love
you Breakers we love you roomies uh have
a great rest of your day late Escape is
I'll be the same time adios this Morgan
Shoes
thank you
[Music]